- When Marie Curie shared the
1903 Nobel Prize for Physics
with two other scientists,
her husband Pierre Curie
and Henri Becquerel,
she had been the first
woman to win the prize,
or maybe we have no error.
So what feels a little
fishy is this had been,
this had been right over here.
We're referring to a
specific moment in the past.
When Marie Curie shared
the 1903 Nobel Prize.
So if we're speaking a
specific moment in the past,
so if this is the
present, this is the now,
and we're speaking about a
specific moment in the past,
if that is the past right over there,
you would just use the simple past tense.
So instead of saying she had been,
you would just say she was.
She was the first woman to win the prize.
Let's read that without
this little clause here.
When Marie Curie shared
the 1903 Nobel Prize
for Physics with two other scientists,
she was the first woman to win the prize.
Yeah, that sounds right.
So the error right over here is C.
You would use had been, that's
actually the past perfect.
You kind of throw that had before the verb
to make the past perfect
when you're talking about
something that happened
before something in the past.
So you could say, before I ate lunch,
I had washed the car.
So you would use that past perfect to say,
look, I washed my car before
I did something else in the past,
before I actually ate my lunch.
But here we're not talking about
her doing something before
something in the past.
We're talking about
something that's happening
in an exact moment in the past.
When she won the Nobel Prize,
she was the first woman to win the prize.
So the error here is in C.